today we're gonna be turned into
mermaids did we get it my name is Rachel
Smith I'm the head mermaid at the dive
bar in Sacramento California the bar
that hosts a 40-foot saltwater aquarium
and we have mermaid shows every single
night as a woman I think mermaids appeal
to me because they're part of two worlds
ocean and land they're not really quite
sure where you belong but you're still
this confident and alluring sort of
creature today I'm going to be training
two fabulous ladies and transforming
them into mermaids
we are excited and scared I don't
believe in mermaids I hope today that
changes everyone wanted to be Ariel
growing up and now I will finally be the
brown Ariel when I train the girls today
I think there'll be some surprises
it looks so graceful and pretty and
their hair looks perfect even though
it's underwater
oh no being a professional mermaid is
actually a lot of hard work it's
athletic this is real and the tails can
be up to 35 pounds are we kidding
the water is often very cold you have to
swim with grace and strength today will
probably change their lives
Michels wellness I brought these lovely
shells for you thought we're going to
have you in this lovely seaweedy top you
know I can't say that I've worn anything
like this before
I can't say have dreamed of wearing
things like and of course you both get
your mermaid aisle on climb in this one
little fishy already mermaid makeup is
super challenging because it has to stay
on underwater
my face is blinged out bling-bling feel
like never any buffer okay ladies it's
time to fit Oh No now we can't walk you
know you have to do this like fish tanks
the tightest pair pants I've ever put on
and we'll go over my butt tail wave to
the camera hips don't lie
you look fine I look fine girl okay we
need to take a photo shoot so the thing
about posing as a mermaid you really
want to rotate your shoulders back and
down oh my god oh I feel sexier just do
all right
always always point your toes this is a
person this is a movie
we're officially mermaid people he's
taught to swim now we're gonna learn the
basic mermaid swim nice and slow
great swimming is just working mark
yes Michelle yes Michelle
so much of a professional mermaid is
looking great we're going to learn
bubble kisses
put your hand on your mouth make a nice
tight seal and then you're gonna throw
your bubbles forward like that I cannot
get up
last thing I wanted to try with you guys
was a tail stand
I'll try the game temple I need a circle
around me analyze
we did it but you too we are mermaids
you have to be coordinated and athletic
I am neither but I now see that it takes
a lot of work
I felt sexy underwater not a book
because when I got above water I was
like oh [ __ ] I'm like drowning I have so
much respect for the women in men who
practice and rheumatism I'm never ever
in my life going to forget this it's
here it's here here what get it they're
fine I got it get it get it and get it
it's here quick